ensuite ce sera bientôt tolérance zéro
pour les non vacciné le gouvernement
réfléchis à durcir ses restriction face
à un taux de vaccination complet
d'environ 66 % de la population deux
options sont sur la table limiter
l'accès aux espaces intérieurs aux
personnes avec port du masque
obligatoire bien fermer les endroits où
il n'est pas possible de le porter dans
les deux cas de télétravail obligatoire
pour rappeler visiter tout comme
l'enseignement à distance dans les
universités un délai a été accordée
jusqu'à mardi à chaque quand on est
milieu professionnel pour qu'ils donnent
leur position Ariel spécialiste en santé
publique doute de l'efficacité de ces
mesures
au niveau scientifique honnêtement je ne
vois pas ce que ça pourrait changer
par rapport à l'évolution des épidémies
que vous avez la Suisse c'est un petit
pays mais c'est surtout des grands
aéroports c'est très international et
donc il y a beaucoup de
l'étranger et de communauté de culture
et effectivement il y a des cons partout
il y a des personnes qui qui qui voit
d'un mauvais œil une autre vision
vaccinal qui ne comprennent pas
obligatoirement lui qui pense qu'ils ne
sont pas une population cible le monde
entier subit les Suisses au milieu de la
de l'Europe subi saucisse et demi je
dirais même ses différentes épidémies
parce que à chaque variant et un nouveau
virus avec ses propres caractéristiques
donc on s'attend en tant que le médecin
et scientifique à ce type de virus sur
combine et
[Musique]
l'histoire naturelle de